She's Gotta Have It--I was
the Caterer, the Producer,
the Director, the
Screenwriter, acted in it,
and I was the 1st--we
didn't have a 1st AD.
Why?
We didn't have the money.
When you're an independent
filmmaker and making films
outside of Hollywood,
that's hard.
You have to pray on bended
knee at that church of cinema.
But you have these tools that
could help you tell a story.
Want to show someone
who is a little weak?
You shoot them from above.
Want to show
someone who is powerful?
You shoot them from below.
Well, there's a
dynamic that you get
with the movement of camera.
Film is about movement.
For the writers--
You know what
the f*** that means?
Yeah, it means pay me
my mother******’ money.
Here's the thing--
why this works.
When you think about
it, they're both right.
That really makes s*** dramatic
when both people have beliefs,
and then, you have
them come head to head.
I owe you fifty bucks.
You keep it.
No, you keep it.
There's been a history
of American cinema, which
has denigrated, defamed,
belittled, dehumanized.
It's documented.
The Klan used Birth of a
Nation to lynch black folks.
As a filmmaker, you know, it's
not something to play with.
It's going to take many decades
to retell these stories.
And I knew that one way that I
could do something about this
was to make films for
a diverse audience
to show black people in all
our glory, faults, warts,
and what not.
Just grab the camera and go.
Fight to get your
vision on the screen.
In short of killing
somebody, robbing, I mean,
you're gonna do what you have
to do to get this thing made.
Majority of the people on
this earth go to the grave
having worked a job
they’ve hated their whole life.
So, if you're able to make a
living doing what you love,
you've won.
I'm Spike Lee, and this
is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]